yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby
here's here's how
I the routa
Twins and uh the boys the boys all the
boys the first thing I noticed is
they've been they've been rolling since
they were three and you guys don't have
cauliflower ears that's the first thing
secondly I swear to God I can't believe
you're not Surfers cuz you have Surfer
energy no they are Surfers you are
Surfers like high level you're high
surface too yeah he was just in Costa
Rica he was like in Hawaii talking about
surfing and I was like they monsters so
you spend your time rolling and surfing
There's Nothing Better h so H so used
hen so Gracie said if he hadn't been
into that into Jiu-Jitsu he would have
been a surfer CU in Brazil they just
would hit the waves and then they would
it's like peanut butter and jelly like
surfing Jiu-Jitsu most highle guys I
know are really good balance there's so
many like that's living you're that's
that's the way imagine being 18 being at
their level wait you're 18 uh no 20 20
now but yeah so imagine being at their
age but you guys been doing this for how
long you know what I'm saying like at
this level since before I can remember
you got your black Bel at 18 17 years 18
years old 18 imag being 18 black belt
and then you're surfing competing high
level Jiu-Jitsu I mean I mean your dad
got it right man thank you he got it
right we're clones of our Pops pretty
much is your dad that way started
surfing yeah sorry we started like
training surfing everything at the same
time we're like 3 years old yeah him
right there D Dad Dad
mat strive to be like him he can still
get barreled in overhead waves blackbell
Subs many people you know all of us want
to believe our dads can beat up your dad
your dad can beat up everybody's D's
he's a Savage and he'll steal and he'll
steal your mom too that's classic cuz
all of our friends growing out you're
like your dad is so scary like like he's
so intimidating we're like really like
we just never see it's our CS you don't
see it in your pot so all of our friends
like and and your your dad since a young
age was like I he didn't have to push
you guys in jit too but if you see Dad
doing that your hero you guys just
organically did it and then he's like
damn maybe we got something here exactly
I mean it was before we were training he
was always messing with us you know just
throwing us around you know so before we
were poty trained I mean we were like in
diapers and he was just messing around
with us all the time wrestling with us
and stuff that's we literally that was
the only thing holding us back at the
time from from actually doing a Jitsu
class was the fact that we weren't potty
trained yeah when did you when they
potty trained us boom all right we're
dad's like they can do it they just [__]
their exactly he's like they sh did you
guys ever have did you ever feel like
was there ever a moment where you were
like oh this is I'm really good at this
or was it always just a what you did so
it just kind of it happened organically
it was super organic yeah so organic
this is what you did second nature it
was until like until we started Landing
our first couple sponsors and and we
first started making our first bits of
money and we started feeling like
pressure when we started competing like
that what age was that brother what age
was that when you first started like 12
right damn give her a take we got
sponsored by Ruka like 11 I think we
were right yeah like 11 or 12 imagine
Ruka Ruka is massive the big big
Building Company especially that long
ago like massive you're 11 so would you
go to school like what are we doing at
that point that was pretty much when we
started homeschooling from that then on
so it's was like I think fourth or fifth
grade we started yeah fourth grade on we
started homeschooling and your pops like
obviously he doesn't plan this stuff but
if you're getting he he ran with it yeah
like all right this what we're going to
do you're going to train plan was always
pretty clear at that point we were
pretty much always in the adult classes
already you know so that was mostly in
the morning the training was your dad a
teacher of Jiu-Jitsu or just a
practition he did teach he did teach but
uh he's both mostly a practitioner but
uh wherever we were training he Al if
they needed help you know up until we
were 12 he taught us pretty much
everything really so now now that you
guys are competing like this do you feel
you have to constantly evolve and and
look at what other people are doing do
do you do do you feel like you have to
like know what the wrestlers are doing
what that how does that work that's just
part of staying at the top you know you
got to always be evolving making sure
that nobody's you know on some new stuff
that you haven't figured out yet you
know there's always some stuff you got
to you know that you haven't quite
figured out and there's so many moving
parts so it's just making sure you're at
the top of as much as you can be you
know a lot of is the the guys chasing
you guys though too a lot of it's that
you know what I've been noticing a lot
trying to keep up with them yeah a lot
of now you starting to see a lot of the
same techniques that we were kind of
known for using they see a lot of the
guys starting to kind of replicate it's
kind of using some of the same
strategies and things like that
interesting to see what mom say when Dad
was like here's what we're going to do
we're going to homeschool these little
bastards and then we're just going to
train nonstop my mom was more down
should make money my mom
yeah M bear is gnarly so fun was so was
she an athlete as well or just she just
yeah she grew up doing sports her prime
she had a bit of a neck injury it kind
of like kept her out of j- jit she
started training a little bit um she
paddled canoe a lot growing up so she
did like random thing she lived in uh
Maui for like eight years that's we were
born actually so yeah you born in Hawaii
right yeah exactly and is that where you
started first started surfing no we we
moved from there when we were very young
like a year year old or something like
that yeah I don't remember my time there
but uh so we we were raised in
Huntington Beach California I think it's
interesting too cuz in Jiu-Jitsu
especially when I was coming up it was
almost like a baseball Vibe where you
don't want to shine with your
personality and now with social media
and the direction Jitsu is going like
what Eddie's done with ebi you know
there's so many different Avenues now
you can make big time money being a
Jiu-Jitsu practitioner it's like these
personalities are coming out man and
it's it's gaining more fans and more
fans it I mean you guys are one of the
reasons you know it's like you guys
you're guys dude your guys' personality
I mean if you want to make it in
Hollywood probably could very easily
make it like you're just having be
badass stay out of we did one Metro PCS
convers yeah what's up two for one two
for
one like the twins off Big Daddy no but
um but it's it's rare in jiujitsu now
all these personalities coming out and
the ones that are coming out there
happen to be the very best in the world
tip of the spare and then the best
personalities it's great to see like you
look at Gordon Ryan Craig Jones we
talked about you boys there's like so
many badasses Man sport just great for
the sport and then one Championship
comes along and was like all right well
now you guys can be professionals I want
give you a world title I was like I said
I was at your fight in Denver y yeah I
got that one done super stoked and then
got the title since then we both got the
title yeah for one now so we're super
stoked there and they Corner each other
say of course he went against MMA guy
who's a stud but I was telling him it it
it never made sense to me when they do
MMA versus highle grapple cuz the MMA
guy is not going to play the game so
it's not that exciting well why cuz
stall keep yeah yeah it's difficult you
know like in Jitsu it requires two guys
to really want to fight you know to make
it exciting you know and you don't
really know who wants to fight until
they're in there you know so it's tough
but I would imagine MMA is more just
trying to neutralize so they he can
blast you in the face as opposed to you
know engaging yeah no I'm saying they're
doing straight Jiu-Jitsu it's a MMA guy
who he's a black belt but there's black
belts I have a black
Bel level oh my gosh yeah it's a big
different black have you ever rolled
with an MMA guy that gave you
fits yeah I'm sure
uh so hum did you see that he goes he
goes yeah I'm sure I don't think both
got quiet I Brian realizes how good you
guys are at
jiujitsu there's some very tough like
like you know MMA guys out there without
a doubt like name a few darinho dho for
sure you know who's uh surprisingly
tough who you don't he's not really
known for his Jiu-Jitsu but Luke rockold
has great Luke
rock monster L me nuts cuz I knew how
good he was at grappling and he would
never use it and he would never use it
be world champion take these [__]
guys down he's got he's busy with khabib
and all those guys over at AKA John
Fitch that's we Daniel Cormier he was
training with he learned from Daniel
Cormier and Kane velasque they all came
up yeah he can serve too that's right
his brother I think was a professional
profal Luke's a serious athlete he's
bigger than you guys too he's a big
Luke's massive 220 yeah you
guys 190 probably close to I'm in
between 175 180 right now hey and guys
and guys that's a wrestling 185 that's a
grappling 185 that's some
density I don't know what that means
that's it's true it is a different what
else is interesting I it just happens
like even in the podcast or comedy world
there's like these beefs and ji Jitsu
there's I feel like now it's like
there's always these beefs it's good for
drama and people pick up on it got to
yeah sell the show there there's be like
you guys had beef with Gordon Ryan a
little bit right like Gordon's my boy
Gordon I love him man all just a little
small Petty things that started you know
escalating and then the social media
gets a hold of it and it's like you know
Real Housewives of bra ji- jits EXA
exactly exactly hey B let's take a
little break dude let's take a break
I'll tell you what unlike the Rolo twins
uh I won't be in Costa Rica but I will
be in Chicago Chicago Friday Saturday
both shows jiujitsu semar or again not
like them dude doing standup comedy yep
I'll be on stage so my life not as cool
as those guys I will be in freezing
Chicago December 8th and 9th that's this
Thursday and Friday I'm in Nashville and
Austin get your tickets at thick boy.com
well you know what's funny is this
weekend starting tomorrow I'll be at the
Helium Comedy Club in Indianapolis I
said it out loud it's not warm there
either no it's not buddy and then the
spaan comedy club where I want to go
goose hunting I don't know if it's going
to happen but if I'm not goose hunting
Brennon I'll be doing stand up the
December 15 16 great Comedy Club I can't
wait and then off the hook I'm not
stopping can't stop won't stop Florida
December 21 to 23 and then Comedy Zone
Charlotte North Carolina December 29 to
31 dude you know what would make these
dates easier if you had a gallon of
macadamia milk well you know what's
funny is if you go to House of
macadamias and you get the healthiest
nut on the planet for you with Omega 7
fatty acids that is great for satiety
that a lot of people that are into
longevity take macadamia nuts although
they're super expensive but guess what
house of macadamia has cornered figed
out they got 90 Farmers they work with
all right and they're giving you a
gallon of macadamia milk I put in my
coffee it is Silky Smooth well it's
buttery it tastes buttery and nutty and
delicious and it's not if you're lactose
intolerant don't worry about it cuz it's
100% pure macademia and you can get that
free gown of macademia milk when you
visit House of academia.com
TFK just add the milk to your cart with
any products use the code TFK that's
House of macademia
docomo's out of your weight class he's a
giant
anyway but they still have to go you
know in absolute ADCC
EXA the funniest thing is when you watch
them especially when they're kids going
against grown men and rolling them up
imagine being a grown man like look at
these two there are there are
14-year-olds that will take you as a gr
it was them dude was always that was
always us growing up you know taking on
the bigger guys it's like Gordon's still
on the list for sure you know it's
always kind of this like yeah he's for
sure know he knows it yeah and that's
what even a lot of our drama came
through he's good at like creating it
you know talking about numbers and that
kind of stuff yeah and he
talk brilliant guy but the thing too
with it like it's good for everybody
what Gordon's doing you know Gordon's a
seven figure athlete bro seven figure
and Jiu-Jitsu Gordon don't have to do
[__] Gordon Gordon just does you know
his his online seminars he posted a
thing someone's making fun of his like
money or something he's like say what
son and posted how much he makes a month
like that's a Hew much as we hate him
like as much people hate him like he's
he's a high high level businessman new
standard financially that's he's also
he's also incredible at what he does who
hates him how do you you can have beef
it's fun but to hate an artist of that
level like hating you guys like when you
get that good at something that it takes
everything to be that good right how
many hours prac have to respect what
he's doing in the time that he's putting
into his craft you know 100% especially
in a world like the thing about jiujitsu
is is it's pretty much been corrupted by
steroids for forever so everyone's been
on steroids so it's almost it's almost
like how is it cheating if everyone's
doing it I feel like it's their mindset
you know what I'm me going into it so
it's like it is hard to say like yeah
you can't disregard everything he's done
cuz everyone else is doing it too you
know what I mean it's like baseball back
in the day when they hate on like B Bond
Samy s I'm like yeah but the pitchers
run steroids so who's at fault it's like
every you know so yeah exactly that's
like the the the argument I guess you
say you can make but also like the true
essence of Jiu-Jitsu at least always was
was the smaller guy beating the bigger
guy you know the that's why we're known
as like the roots that's why we try to
keep as root you know as natural as
possible you years just trapped out
Grace he take on this huge guy and all
of a sudden he's choking him out how did
that guy just beat him you know that was
my dad he was always super into that and
you know I feel like over time Jiu-Jitsu
has been it's been starting to lose that
you know like that that it has a little
bit and I think um and it's nobody's
fault it's just entertainment and when
you don't have those regulations in
place guys are going to go wild right
like I when I that's happening in the
law sports right every sport like when I
was in the UFC if I could have got away
with it just to compete I probably would
have done steroids I just I could afford
it and the guys I was fighting against
could but there was no reason not to
like in baseball it's like why not do it
why not and then I sign a 7ye $400
million contract you know but if you
guys can you guys are bring it back to
the the the root like you said the roots
juu got away from that because I think
they couldn't get attention you know
like you guys there's so many badasses
man there's just you weren't getting the
viewership you weren't getting the
attention and then these monsters come
out like you watch goord right like
Jesus Christ man animal anal going to
make it so much better when you get
naturally it's coming soon you know it's
coming soon I know it's going to take a
lot longer you know but yeah it's on you
know I can't wait for
that well there's a purity like that you
guys represent you know I think that's
an important thing to hold on to 100%
it's weird cuz you guys have been famous
for especially in the Jitsu world since
you were I don't know three [__] in your
pants and then now yeah you guys are I
mean they're not jaded you know there's
no ego there's no well but be because
you're always competing and always
working and it sounds to me correct me
if I'm wrong you guys do a lot of
rolling together so metal sharpens metal
right like that's it a million 10% it
must be so weird to have the same kind
of bodies and almost brains and you're
rolling together how does that work is
it constant they say it all the time
it's a sport like chess you know you're
always trying to guess your opponent's
next move right when you have a twin
brother you already kind of know his
next move anyway you know so then when
you roll together so much your whole
lives it's just like like even you can I
can fight someone so big so strong it's
always worth fighting my brother you
know cuz technique is always more scary
than strength like we know what we want
to do so far ahead of what we know when
we're actually doing it you know so it's
always just like a mental battle exactly
do you find do you find though that
you're competitive do you find like if
he pushes you're going to push back is
it it's just natural right you can't
help it I can't yeah we push harder each
other than we do anyone else I've heard
stories I've heard stories about you
guys where you'll clear the mat where
it'll be like like you'll start rolling
and then pretty soon an hour later
you're still going at it that the thing
and we get so pH you know there's things
like like we roll with each other like
we would never roll with other people
you know what I mean like it gets to a
level of intensity that we could never
like feel good about doing that to
someone else you know what I mean but
it's our brother so we could slap you
know and it's all good out but it's like
you know there's some days where I seen
my like Professor Angelica like with her
mouth open like like we're just boxing
basically you know
bullet and then afterwards it's all love
you know so maybe a little eggy for like
a minute or two but do
you do you practice with wrestlers do
you do any takeown stuff like with the
dastani stuff like that Russian not with
them in particular we always worked all
of kind of the forms of martial arts and
just growing up you know Wrestling Judo
you know hop into like some high school
wrestling classes some you know random
Judo schools things like that and so we
always just my parents were always
really good at just kind of making can
sure we were like well vers everywhere
trying to keep us well-rounded and you
stayed injury free which is my
impression of everybody who does
Jiu-Jitsu is this I gotta N I got I'm
getting back into it right now I'm just
it's like the CrossFit guys yeah was
injured same [__] but did you your your
parents they had to put put putting you
guys in this there had to be a a plan
right like there was a plan as far as
cuz they they would they couldn't just
like right no school today just do
Jiu-Jitsu so I'm I'm that's a good
question I'm so curious about your dad
like as a dad it it'd be hard for me to
pull him out of school I'm like these
kids got it cuz everyone thinks your kid
has it especially with where Jiu-Jitsu
was at that point too right like that's
that's a good you know especially at
that time like you know Jiu-Jitsu got
the best of the best weren't really
making money off of competing they were
making money off of once they got that
championship title then they can teach
seminars open up their gyms and it was
almost like a college degree you know
what I mean and then you can you know
kind of work off usually people get so
good at Jitsu and the the plan is just
open a gym that's where you make your
money right it'd be tough to want that
for your kids you know like don't get me
wrong it's a good life but I think the
second that R sponsorship that showu
sponsorship the second we started
getting some some real money and you
know we're like hold on they're they're
they're kids and they're making our you
know 1500 bucks each back then K and I
were some are like the only kids making
YouTube videos you know like highlight
ones you know my mom was putting them
together clipping them together and then
those are starting to actually get you
know some views yeah and we I feel like
we kind of like the first kids to kind
of start you know having some sort of
following you know as massive your mom
and dad so they were like oh this could
kind of go somewhere you know and then
we got that first sponsorship from Ruka
and then they're like okay we're
committed it's kind of wild to commit to
something like that you know it's the
risk
obviously like damn Mom there was very I
feel like just very few like kids in in
in the world at that time that had been
training since they were potty trained
you know what I mean so like especially
in Jiu-Jitsu Jiu-Jitsu in particular
there's very few in the world at that
time right so it's like such a small
percentage you know as long as we kind
of stayed with it my son is in Jiu-Jitsu
right now it's the first thing at 12
that he's taken to like a fish to water
no way like there's something about it
that he he just he couldn't he didn't
like team sports and the minute he got
on a mat and he started learning stuff
he he got he got obsessed and now he he
has to go it's like I don't have to
motivate him you know it's so cool it's
such a it's a it's such a game changer
man really I've seen seen it all I've
seen kids that hate it their first month
and then all of a sudden you know like
one day something just clicks something
clicks and they love it every do you
guys do you guys ever suffer from I know
some twins suffer from my identity
Christ a little bit right cuz you're
both these badass world champions but
it's you're twins I me even though he
grew his hair out he still look exactly
the same I love that hair I wish I could
have hair like that when he when he grew
it out we like what the [__] you
doing so good looking if I had hair like
that so much conditioner at the end of
the day so much
condition like what's going on
spending money in you start noticing it
spending money in condition hey you know
what take it from a guy with hair like
mine that's worth it that sh R has no
choice man I got no choice but to keep
father times his bar Mouse Brown
div classic yeah but would your parents
I I hate when people do this with twins
when they dress them the same your
parents ever do that when we were real
young we did that you know and then yeah
we started growing up we're like all
right we're going to clip that
immediately that was pretty quick we
clipped that you get burned out you ever
get of it do you ever think about I how
do you keep yourself our parents are
always so good at us you know they
worked us super hard you know we were
training a lot but anytime that we got
burn out we'd go surf or go to Costa
Rica yeah every want I feel like as a
family we'd go to Costa Rica for a month
once a year you know I think what made
them very okay with us taking breaks is
like we'd go take that month break or
whatever right and we just wouldn't
touch Jiu-Jitsu for the month and we'd
come home and we'd be training better
than before come back refreshed and just
and we were missing it you know we were
just like excited to be there and we
were just fired yeah just smash your
parents figured it out figured it's
mindblowing to me but it also they also
had two kids that had a certain
Constitution you know you you you there
are some people it sounds like you just
not everybody can do what you do you you
obviously had something that took to it
and and I think the hardest thing well
it's also the the hardest thing is just
being able to show up every day right
and and that's not easy I think it was
expected though yeah there C there's
certain parents that have expectations
mhm you know yeah man yeah it was what's
the saying it feels like you're you're
hardly working you know but you're
working hard you know that's what it was
our whole lives you know like it just
felt like part of life going to
Jiu-Jitsu you know and that's why we
were homeschooled honestly we we felt
like it we were taking the easy route
out we're like we don't have to go to
school like like proper proper school
you know what I mean like we don't have
to go to college like like how many
hours a day I just want to fight how
many how many hours a day did they did
you roll have you would as a kid um
growing up it was a lot yeah I'd say
growing up we trained more growing up
than we do now on a on a weekly basis
about that [__] but to your Dad's credit
like we're going to do this you're going
to do it you're going to do it they're
so committed yeah what does your dad do
was he for a living what what got him
too back then he was uh shaping
surfboards and doing construction wow
you know and then uh back then uh you
know his job got a little bit shaky
right when we got sponsored by Ruka you
know and that's when it was on you know
as far as Jutsu goes I think that's
another reason why it was so super you
know they were so like handson they seen
yeah they seen the future that that we
can you know that they saw something
there do you guys feel pressure from
that at all not really I feel like still
at that age we were still so like just
like yeah la la land literally just
didn't think about it that way like oh
we're just surfing and training you know
it still didn't feel like worked at that
time yeah cuz there's my son's in in
baseball he's pretty good baseball
player and there's some dads on that
team I can feel the pressure they put on
their son like man this ain't it bud
theid K playing seven days a week
they're playing were they like you
though the fathers no no no no no no no
there you go no no there you go like I
think I just I feel bad for the kids I'm
like the wrestling
tournaments you see those dads it's like
you want this he doesn't dude give him a
break kid's like 12 lbs dehydrated he
got like six ring
worms let him
go like God
hilarious that's tactic it is what it
takes but I think it's really
interesting that like you've gotten to
this point as a competitor and you don't
think of it as work that's what I think
is interesting you guys seem so easy
going man it's such a to what degree do
you drill like how much is there in
drilling to get super good at something
like John Doner has talked about like it
takes five years if you train like five
hours a day you can get really good at
anything John Don said anybody if you
really want to get really good at
anything whether it's guitar Jiu-Jitsu
if you take five years you train five
hours a day with the right teacher you
can get world class at anything right
now whether or not that's true you have
to cons the that's like saying if you
eat a lot of food you're going to get
big but but but what is what degree is
that like no [__] and as far as world
class I disagree with them well iig true
yeah but but I but but what would you
say uh how to what ratio is it drilling
where you drill versus live wrestle well
everyone learns a different way too you
know like for my brother and I that's
the number one thing that I've noticed
like out of all things is everyone
there's not one path to Victory there's
not one right way every single person
has a different way to do things you
know some people may like work out twice
a day three times a day my brother and I
we don't really work out at all you know
what I mean and when I mean obviously we
do body weight we do surfing we do like
different you know different types of
exercis not at Gold's Gym like we're not
at Gold Gym Pumping Iron you know the
amount of people every single one of my
professors are telling oh you need to
sit there like lift all these we no
that's not what we do it's just like
I've tried it like you know month in I
just didn't like it I didn't I didn't
like just like I started my tight my
joints didn't feel good I'm like some
people who have these they can't even
lock a darts they can't even lock a
buggy choke I'm like I like the mobility
you know I like so I feel like every
everyone has a different uh path to you
know to success or some people like
drilling a lot you know some people just
need to drill it into their minds you
know for them to learn my brother and I
were like that a little bit but never
really too much either you know we were
always just kind of like what we would
do is we' work backwards from a problem
you know like let's say the heel hook
situation
my brother and I we both got heel hooked
really bad when we first did the ADCC
trials as kids you know we got our knees
and ankles popped damn so we growing up
we had only done like IB ggf style
competitions right and there's no leg
locks so we just kind of we doing we
were doing great on everything except
for that I think we both made a couple
matches you know smashing people from
the outside and then we finally got leg
locked both of us and as we walked away
limping okay we got to figure this out I
remember the next day we're all limping
around like New York mom's like stop
limping you're fine it hurts mom's a
Savage she's a
Sav Savage yeah and I remember we get to
the garage and we get we just put each
other in the Y you know fig we work
backwards so then we'll work backwards
technically and then it's and then it's
boom then it's training what a blessing
have another person who's involved as it
would have usually it's one person this
person might be really talented but have
the same dedication but you guys have
each other man I it took like 6 months
straight of every day just like figuring
out that 50 like the heel Hooks and like
he said starting from it's it's starting
from the problem starting from the heel
hook what's what's creating the torque
okay this it's the hips it's the grip
it's the feet okay so we need to close
the distance the first thing right and
you know heels slip to you know just
figuring out step by step like that but
also to to your credit like that that's
just the kind of transformation
Jiu-Jitsu like leg locks and heel Hooks
and you know the 50/50 guard like all
that stuff started popping
off cyclical if you kind of like if you
really like
focus on it like I think it was more so
cuz leg locks were always considered
dirty you know like back in the day in
Brazil if guys are doing leg locks
they're throwing shoes on them at some
plastic bottles and it was just no one
had leg lock they're very frowned upon
so it was like obviously let's take the
one thing that no one really did just
cuz it was kind of like against the
rules even though it wasn't and fixate
on it and people ran with that was that
was uh Dean LST and and Don yeah they
would do that but then in the UFC it was
that remember PA palah haris Paar and he
he he would pop people's he was a dick
people ha no it's called a dick that guy
that guy tried to Blind Jake Jake Shield
I saw it that that guy was a dick yeah
he do some gnarly stuff but I remember I
remember when Nate was getting ready to
fight and we were training with Nate and
Nate's a high Lev black girl he's been
doing a long time and even he was like
in the weeds with those leg locks and I
was like oh [__] this isn't like they
had to bring in a
speci all yeah they started special guys
who were like specialists at it like uh
you know Paul hares and then the other
black belts are like I don't know this
language man yeah was scary it's so
scary those ankle lock and then you seen
it Go all full circle you see like like
Nikki Ryan for example you know I
remember he amazing leg Locker leg
locking everyone you know and then uh I
had a really good match with them you
know and shut down all of his leg locks
and then after that you turn into like a
really good wrestler know boom and then
you see all this now there's the big
wrestling push right now everyone's
becoming a good wrestler again yeah I
was going to ask you that like once
everybody figures out the like in in
anything whether it's a box gym or
Jiu-Jitsu gym if you're in the same with
the same group of people it starts
getting incestuous like you can tell
somebody's got patterns so you're like I
know what this guy's going to do so now
you're ahead of him so he's he's a
whatever he's an ankle lock guy or he's
a triangle guy or boxing he's going to
shut it down yeah you can shut it down
so like one of the things I guess that's
where competition comes in because you
you you're seeing looks you've not seen
before it's not what you see in the in
your gym right do you bring people in
who you who who are different that way
is that how you stay Sharp or do you
definitely if you can it helps you know
sometimes you don't always have that
ability but for sure if you can I think
one thing that we've always really
focused on just something that we could
just do with each other is just focus on
our reactions even when I teach seminars
like this is what I tell right when I
start the seminar like most seminars I
go even before I teach like before we
teach any techniques today I just like
the main thing I want you guys to kind
of get through your mind is like you
know how important reactions are it's
like kind of take it away how how we we
go over reactions well yeah it's just
it's it's all about timing even for his
whole ADCC performance this last one you
know that in particular huh that in
particular yeah yeah there's this it's
really even hard to explain to be honest
with you you know but there's certain
techniques that can as long as you react
in the right time you know you
neutralize it you neutralize it behind
there is a reaction for every technique
every technique there's a reaction for
there's a Escape there's a defense for
every technique out there right and even
if there isn't there's there's one ready
to be made you know so it's really just
standing and adding that to your to your
your quiver of techniques you know like
it's you don't need to know every single
technique you know but as long as you
have a reaction you know for every
single you know problem that occurs then
then you're going to be able to win the
match that's like someone my friend a
right now that we're trying to explain
to him cuz his Jiu-Jitsu is
amazing a lot of really good Jiu-Jitsu
but he makes a he still makes a lot of
mistakes you know and I in trouble
sometimes at the end of the day it's
just whoever makes the the least amount
of mist your level almost something as
simple as this like Ty like grab like
this right here like like a collar grip
boom like a collar grip before I used to
like try to break this with all my power
we're finding these adults and these
guys are twice three times our strength
they're never going to break this grip
you know but like the second like say
we're standing I can you know boom they
go drop Sagi whatever the case is I
cannot break this the second I duck
under it it's so useless like this grip
is useless I could go outside single
knee Taps it's pointless to have this
grip right I can start kind of rushing
tying this just you adapting too it's
like I can't break the grip right but I
have to react to it so I could put it in
a position where that grip is now
useless if that makes anage for I can't
wait till somebody grabs my
[__] and I'm be likeo
technique two onone here and drive that
look at my Gable grip [__] dude I can't
wait you guys ever get stressed out you
guys seem pretty stress free man well I
was going to say about young stresse
this guy clearly just came back from
off the
boat but there's a LEL when you m like
when you're working for Mastery like I
was I was listening to you talk when
you're working for Mastery like this and
you're getting so good at something and
always staying sharp I correct me if I'm
wrong but I feel like you you naturally
will end up having to live a clean life
in one way or another so so they're like
there's no there's no room for [__]
or lying on the mat you've got to be
honest with yourself and there's always
somebody breathing down your neck so
you've got to constantly that that
process of like it requires a certain
amount of self-restriction there's no
room for complacency really yeah yeah
and that requires dedication Excellence
it's like Excellence it's life Mastery
you know cuz you're talking the way you
talk you guys are saying stuff that I
like there's no true way right there's
all different kinds of way you would
never understand that unless you had
done what you're doing and I always say
there are two things I was thinking
about a lot there are a lot of people I
know they might be uccessful they might
have an audience but most of their life
has been spent listening to what people
say and read listening about life and
reading about life they're not doing
life there's something about putting
your hands on the world literally where
you learn things you could never learn
from a book so I could read all the I
could read as I could read all the books
on Jiu-Jitsu I can read I'm never gonna
yeah unless I do it yeah yeah and I feel
like you guys are like this too again
going back to your parents taking you
guys out of school folks son Jiu-Jitsu
some people like oh but they didn't have
friends and stuff like no no no only did
they have friends they had more friends
than probably your kids in this weird
school more real friends yeah real legit
friends and then also you guys were like
working on something these other kids
experience a lot too you know you know
traveling different gyms you know
different you know like the education
your parents gave you life is way better
also not like we were just like Little
Gym Rats too at the same time we were at
the we were at the beach most of the day
you know what I mean surfing so dude
it's be really awkward when I bring my
son to your father and tell him to raise
him this is my son is yours until he's
20 see you when you're 20 to Costa Rico
we got camps going what great time Jitsu
and surfing camps that's that's pretty
much this whole this whole me you guys
figured it out dude that's our that's
our favorite we've been going ever there
ever since we were little I been my
dad's like his little Hidden Gem is
Costa Rica we in he's happiest there the
North Pacific part are you familiar with
Tamarindo bit little bit yeah it's about
an hour south yeah Tamarindo it's it's
right where the jungle meets the ocean
where did we go be we went to Haka H you
guys are a bit down there that's more
like touristy and [__] there's a huge
crocodile on the beach and I was like
[__] this bro there's a lot more Crocs
down that way yeah really have you seen
down that way not where you guys are
there's less some and the rainy season
they come out a lot more and all the
rivers they kind of [__] all of that
have you ever seen him while you're
surfing I've never seen all all the boys
have you know I've never
seen all of that the saltwater crocs too
right that's right they're brackish
water they'll eat you they're not Nile
Crocs they're they're American
crocodiles a little less aggressive get
up to 25 ft anyway you saw them r r in
this South part where we were you got to
worry about crocodiles and prostitutes
right I didn't know that I didn't know
that we went to a bar and I was like we
went to a bar why is there
literally I literally I was like I need
a condom for my body here this I was
like hold on I know Pros when I see him
literally like we walk in I was like am
I is it my sweater what are these girls
they all we walked in I was like look
where's all the dudes at to sound gay
but where's all the dudes there studs
over there for sure I like we need get
out of here I'm about to get divorced I
got to leave I was like we got to get
out of here 20 bucks was like like
food's
good
machine y'all go swim with the
crocodile yeah place is interesting like
it's like Bangkok I remember last time
we were in Bangkok that that it was too
hectic we're walking right we're we're
with W we're walking and next thing you
know I just feel someone grab my hair
and start pulling and I'm I get knocked
off balance a bit and I was like I was
like rattled like like who is this and
then it was like some I couldn't even a
little I don't know ladyy
a lady boy was doov they loved him over
there well bring is very funny Brian got
a little trouble out I did a movie you
probably haven't heard of Hangover 2 and
uh bring up my character and Hangover 2
and let me show you what I look like
because I got when I was dressed like
this I got more uh looks women were all
about it uh just bring out my character
that's the first one I put no no second
one the second one right
there yeah that one okay I I look a
little bit there you go I had my my skim
was dark and I had I had that wig I look
I mean I'm I'm I'm like your uglier
older
brother but uh but but I but the girls
were all feeling me we shot it we shot
it in in a in a real strip club Cowboy
we were there in a real strip club those
are all real strip and we're doing that
and then when I took my wig off and I
took the makeup off they saw you they
were like a
gross
you wouldn't be that way but you know
they still love you dude come
on I love it no
it's pretty sure I remember that one my
buddy the lady boy there my buddy we
were there we went to see the lady tell
them how you got fooled because it shows
what kind of guy you are nice guy nice
guy tell him this is a prime example
check for the Adam's apple we're still
dating we're still dating he didn't
check and next he's well no that was
that was York that was New York oh was
that New York York you just gay there no
New York I was I met this
beautiful Puerto Rican girl she was
adorable like with a tight little
ponytail so cute her skin I was just
like bro we were dancing I it
waso I was young I was handsome we're
dancing I'm feeling I'm touching her
she's like dude I'm looking at her she
had these almond I was lost in her eyes
and I swear to God I was like this is my
girl forever this is my girl she smells
so [__] good and she had a an apple
bottom like I was like what the [__] is
going on and then there were these phone
booths these phone booths and I took her
in there and I was [__] drinking I
was just bub
slapping kissing like like she owed me
money like kissing like like it was the
last woman on earth and then I reached
down and I went uhoh
hey hand I hope that's a hernia because
that that feels a lot like a
dick tell what you did here's the best
part I pulled back I pulled back and I
can see her look she was so like crushed
cuz I just like that and and about the
thing about me is I can't hurt anybody's
feelings I just can't I went back in
kissed little bit more so I knowingly
kissed a man I said it here and I said
it out loud did to hurt I said it's not
to hurt his feeling and then I pretended
I had a stomach ache went oh my stomach
and I had to get the [__] out of therez
I didn't want her to think him whatever
it doesn't matter now I was in when I
was in when we were in might the nicest
guy I'm a nice guy that's what I'm
saying dud I'm a nice
guy I don't know if I can be that nice
or that good of an actor you would I'd
been like no you can't hurt you're the
same way I am you cannot hurt people's
feelings and you're I'd like take all my
money and you're also a little bit gay
right so I don't think so man hey also
side note I think you knew that was a
lady no no no that that there was a lady
boy that was all over Brody Stevens the
late Brody Stevens the late great Brody
Stevens and she was this this yeah this
was a man who is a woman I'm telling you
I'm telling you I've never seen a woman
that's beautiful and this was a man I
said
bro goo I go if you have sex with this
person you are not gay you are not
you could have stopped at the first
let's change the subject let's change
the subject all right back to jitu let
me run my fingers through your hair
bro
no know how it is you guys you guys have
a pretty like laid-back Vibe like stress
when when do you get stressed when that
time you two got stressed before I feel
like competition days there's a lot of
stress always and then after it's pretty
smooth sailing you know as far as deal
that how do you deal with that
competition just you just show up you
just do what you know just show up
promotions always there's all this extra
stuff at the end of the day it's just a
match you know so just try not to make
it more than that you know you guys have
girlfriends yeah yeah does that ever
cause
issues
no it's funny cuz I'm a year and a half
in he's a week and a half
in damn so she it must be weird that
she's attracted to your brother as
well I we we've heard that a lot but
it's funny they try to act like they no
no you guys are so different
like yeah right okay you're so much
better looking than your
brother like we're identical twins [__]
identical twin have you ever broken up
with a girl and had her well you're so
young so I guess you know imagine you
bring up you don't like me this this is
your first girlfriend and you've had a
few I've had two or this is my second
yeah I've had one it's different
especially at your age at 20 you know
you guys are in Costa Rica competing
here traveling here so they they'd have
to get used to the schedule all over the
place it was just man it keeps you out
of trouble though it's crazy how much
more focused it keeps you it's yeah it's
unbelievable it's so beautiful okay the
last like six months like dude die you
need to be on it dude you know he's all
fired up like what are you talking about
dude just cuz you all up now like he's
all focused love it I the question I
always have is like I guess every kid is
different and sometimes regular school
is good for some kids but I I don't know
if you'd ever regret reget taking your
kid You' know more what do you think
about this like taking your kid and just
getting them really good at anything
like that or or just is it not for every
kid it's not for every like there's some
kids even my son's team now who I was
like y that kid needs to stay in school
yeah like I think their
dad like their dad knows their dad knows
straight up and their dad's been around
the game long enough a lawyer okay yeah
yeah big kid going to be a doctor or
whatever but um baseball's not for him
but um their dad recogniz he's been
around high level stuff so you can tell
you can you just can tell people like at
four I'm like you can tell you can tell
I knew my son was going to be athletic
at you know two oh yeah yeah they put a
ball in his hand like yeah all right he
might be a little bit of an outlier yeah
and then with them you know the dad you
when you just you're around it you just
know you're like oh yeah these kids can
do it if we put them on the right path
you know yeah find your con and then
pursue yeah it's life you guys are so
fortunate basically three you found your
passion that's what most people get in
trouble they graduate college or
whatever and they haven't found their
passion and then depression sets in or
whatever or they go to the military and
they get done they're like what am I
supposed to do man you guys are so
freaking fortunate that your dad
instilled this in you and you guys are
flourishing with
it that's what we're so blessed every
day for that exactly your dad deserves a
freaking award man as
as both our the the coonies your f
[__] father had that envision this
and then it works out you're talking one
in [__] 50 million you know what I'm
saying and not only did he do it with
one he do it with [__] two nuts nuts
unreal it's also a support system man
yeah they well we all that's kind of I
think that's why we always like we don't
really too too much think of our money
as like our money is kind of like our
money you know what I mean so that's
like yeah it's the family's money it's
like every you know all of our like our
one bonuses whatever all of our cash
flow for for the most part it's like
shared throughout the family it's going
towards the the Costa Rica house the gym
things to like kind of just set up
future it's more it's the big picture is
the family that's have sisters or
anything yeah we got a little she's a
badass too
right she was the best growing up you
know so gnarly she's uh 14 now oh my God
yeah she uh she kind of she was feeling
the pressure of like a brother and I you
know she we go to the comps oh you're
fighting the r Bros little sis you know
God she was kind of starting to get over
super cute so cute and she's little
badass too she's a little badass and
she's whatever she does in life she's
going to be successful she's she's
awesome I think she she's a beast for
sure is she in school uh yeah yeah she's
she's homeschooled as well cuz she
started homeschooling right when you
know Jiu-Jitsu was starting to take off
she was an animal and then uh she
started getting phys like we'd showed up
to the competitions and be like oh
you're just the brother sister the Ruto
sister you're fight you know and she'd
feel all this like pressure there' be
extra cameras or whatever you know and
she was like this little girl you know
what I mean I think as young you could
still kind of handle it for a little
girl to have that much pressure how did
she handle it she and she she just she
started getting a little more burnt out
as far as she just wasn't as like
passionate about it and you could see it
and you don't want to for she started
like modeling and becoming more of a
girl and doing girly things
you she was modeling for like Nike and
Crocs and unlo all these all theseand
killing it it's classic cuz she always
just wanted to do what we did in our
whole lives you know just like serve
train you know like little mini us and
now she's like doing her own thing
starting to become for her especially at
14 she's maturing so fast yeah it's
crazy I remember when I was her age we
shared a flip phone right a flip phone
we shared one and we were the only kids
at J justu class with the flip phone and
she's got this brand new iPhone same the
iPhone is the same as her age she's like
an iPhone 14 or something that's not
supposed to work like
that this cannot happen what do you guys
um do you think about the next 10 years
what you wanted to do you want to keep
competing do you want to keep winning
take advantage of my Prime and then just
Retreat to Costa Rica and just surf
every day until I
die pretty much you're not though it's
scary you're not even in your
Prime I mean as long as you guys been
doing it what you probably 26 might
start getting a little dicey 27
dicey you can keep your your Prime will
probably be in your up to
30 far far from it ry's 28 28 I it also
depu every like everyone starts young
now so like the crop of the 20-year-olds
are like the [__] right well those guys
are going to age out and the younger
crop but why wouldn't you get better
it's not like f why not it's just
different the thing about mixed martial
arts I feel like is there's so many
martial arts you can't master Muay Thai
boxing Jiu-Jitsu it's you know how hard
is to master Jiu-Jitsu or to master
boxing one just one alone
and
mix it's I was just talking to someone
the other day I was like considering an
extreme you talk about like extreme
sports you know I consider like surfing
not really an extreme sport big wave
surfing an extreme sport when they're
out there like any one of those can die
on any given moment you know and like I
couldn't I don't even fathom how they do
that you know there's those Wing suiting
guy like there's some things that are
like squirr suits yeah I would never you
know what I mean and then I look at MMA
I consider it like an extreme sport only
because there's so so many I mean elbows
KNE there's so many way to lose it's
wild it's wild you don't everything even
from the weight Cuts guys [__] die
from the weight Cuts you know what I
mean there's a lot of variables that
people aren't even really aware of it's
not something you've ever thought about
right it's not 110% he do it soon yeah
you do yeah yeah I've been training yeah
[__] this my this my argument with that
is you're like you guys are one of the
few faces of Jiu-Jitsu like guys are
such tip of the spare you're doing it
just because it's a think you want to do
like because you're you're you've made
it Jitsu so I never understand like
Mikey mamushi
mamishi he was talking about MMA and I
was just like why though like why man
like you guys are these outliers and you
come over here you know and granted you
guys are going to be damn good but to be
an outlier you know it's going to be I a
handful of people say say that too like
man you guys are paid a lot of money for
just one jiu-ju fight like why why get
punched in the face brother it's fun I
love it for Kate is it's something to
check off the bucket list for us both we
both not even check off the bucket like
you know I was just thinking about this
semi- recently too is like I was
thinking about my my V like what do I
want to be known for as far as like my
legacy you know and like I was thinking
man you could go try to win you know
world six times or ADCC six times or
whatever and I was thinking like yeah I
can do that but like I'm like it would
be super sick if I could you know get a
black belt World title in the ghee it's
it's already hard enough to get one noi
and ghee you know but if I could get one
in the ghee you know I'm an ADCC world
champion right so if I could get the
deal you know uh get a g World
Championship an MMA World Championship
you know get the one title maybe you
know eventually whatever goes from there
UFC whatever may be but just uh I just
want to be able to secure titles in like
you know MMA Jiu-Jitsu what kind of
striking are you doing who's teaching
recently I've been working just a bit
more boxing not been working a bit with
pillo Jason pillo he's my love coach
best to ever do it to ever do it he the
man all nothing but where is he at down
down uh yeah yeah exactly whole Ruka
thing's kind of been it's been fizzled
out they're starting something new now
and a that's right they they shut down
Ruka yeah yeah some um drama basically
with yeah yeah exactly whatever drama
within the brand but basically Pat Tori
the founder of Ruka the the heart and
soul of Ruka uh he's no longer a part of
it he's doing his own new thing and uh
it's going to be massive I think pillo
is going to be a part of it and uh so
yeah are you picking up on do you feel
like you're picking up on boxing quickly
100 I mean I I like to think so for sure
I feel I feel
home with all this CL drop this guy this
body
shot you've been you've been watching
the human body move for a long time so I
always say like if you see a guy like
yel Romero is a freak athlete but still
guys who've been wrestling on a high
level if you've been watching somebody's
body move for that long you get a sense
of space and distance you get an
understanding of patterns and I mean we
grew up watching all the UFC's we we
always a fan of fighting you know what I
mean and then and so now that I just
feel like that I'm actually doing it was
almost just like I put the last six
months I'm just like I just want to
fight like I just want to do it's I I'm
learning something new every single day
I step in there and I'm addicted to that
I'm addicted to that and you have a path
with one Championship too there exactly
you know and I feel like K was always
like an an easier conversion than you
would take like a normal Jitsu guy cuz
we even had like a solid six seven years
of Muay Thai growing up and we always
knew how to throw somewhat straight Pun
It's always so much pushing and pulling
you know it's like that's why none of
these guys you know it's hard to have
like Snap to their punches you know a
lot of us so I feel like Kate actually
has good snap on his punch you know he
he's making the conversion really well
you know so yeah I'm excited to see I
mean we we grew up fighting each other
every day without gloves like fighting
you know I mean like all the
time all the time like like as in like
when you get mad at each other or just
messing around I remember when he got
his first
girlfriend and I I don't know we were
talking [__] you know I think I was just
getting jealous cuz she he he was just
hanging out with her all the time we
were just know I was not surfing with
ever like I'm bored I was going to talk
Talking you know I was talking [__] to
him or whatever he got so pissed I
remember this one VI vividly vividly I
remember we start strapping right
whatever I realize how much intensity
he's coming at me with right so I do a
little Retreat to like one of the
parents bedroom and I like pinned myself
in the back and he tackles me on the bed
and I'm pinned in the corner and he's
choking me with two hands like like and
I couldn't get him off cuz I was pinned
in the corner and I'm like I'm going out
and I'm tapping but he's not letting go
you know I'm like oh I'm going to go out
I could and finally he gave me this scar
here on the eyebrow This Not That gnarly
but like it's definitely prevalent for
sure we've had our fair share you know
great your dad like hey what the [__]
yeah yeah often yeah we try not to do it
in the family house you know like a
20-minute boxing match on the beach one
day we were just arguing in our
apartment in San Diego just like let's
fight and we got our neighbors all
around right so we're like we can't do
it you know we're like not here not here
putes to the car with each other we're
like Side by like
I'm that's rare for
twins twins get along really well you
guys are [__] but you're the same
kind of person so you're both Fighters
so it's like it's like I'm going to
fight myself problem we're so
competitive so we can't let either of us
win get Alpha Al you know that's what it
is it's the alpha yeah so even like when
we do fight like that boxing match on
the beach it was so even for 20 minutes
it was
dude could
like people always say you know if we
could just all realize we're the same it
wouldn't make a difference like you know
how like two different cultures fight
and stuff like that two different
religions we could I I said this in my
last special I was like we could all
look like the same as Penguins we'd find
a reason to hate each other we find a
reason to fight we just cuz you're over
there and I'm over here [__]
you after feel like that's why I've been
so disconnected from my phone recently
like that after understanding that is
I've just been so and it's it's my man
hates me for it you know like
what you feel so much better not being
connected stop you st I did it on an
accident when I F when I went to Costa
Rica this is probably like two years ago
or something like three years ago uh I
went for a week and I forgot my phone
like on the way to the airport in my
apartment and it was too late to turn
back whatever I was like I'm not going
to not go though so we went and I and I
was like the first 4 days just like you
know checking like
my crazy it felt like like a withdraws
and I was like this is not like good you
know so now you just don't and without I
went the whole week after the week like
like the the last you know six whatever
days it was it was just like like I had
completely forgotten about it and all of
the stress in my life like whatever
stress I had I realized it was only
because of that I had no stress in my
life y zero stress except for the
whatever would come on my device you
know damn I always tell people you know
I'll make it when I don't have a cell
phone it be the first thing I get rid of
110 as soon as something some things I'm
working on goes your boy's out exactly
you have to come to my house old school
knock yeah I'm G have a ring phone it's
be sick there's only so much good that
comes from it really that's why guys you
guys are important in this world cuz you
like there's so much just negativ like
you say negativity just negative news
spreads six times faster than positive
right it's always just something
negative the way like especially culture
now like that's the way we're
conditioned like the algorithm promotes
hate promotes netiv where where if if I
post how great you guys are it might get
three or four likes if I post how
horrible you are it gets 500 it's like
why why is a society we like this man
yeah was talking about this recently he
was saying like um he's like I don't
think I want to do uh because there was
somebody I wanted to get I don't know
why ran has a phone I had his money yeah
I agree
pH G he said he said he got so he was so
tired of the [__] negativity because
we were talking about some guy I was
like [__] have him on your podcast
and call him out on this [__] and he
goes yeah I could but I think I'm tired
of all that I I don't think I want to be
negative anymore cuz it Doesn't anything
and it's it's not going to change
anybody's mind he goes I just want to
have people that I'm fascinated I want
to have conversations that are
interesting to me and I want to just be
positive it's really interesting it's
like it's a way better way to live your
life because are you really quote he
said goes the greatness of a man isn't
measure on how much wealth he acquires
but his ability to affect those around
him positively 100% that's like how 100%
Community amen Community but you you
know that's the other thing about when
you get excellent at something you're
setting an example that's why that's why
they they took him down early
yeah I love that clip there's a clip he
goes are you a rich man he goes what you
mean Rich do you have you know what you
mean riches you know cars and and and
houses you call that riches you know it
was a great thing cuz I was like yes yes
I do and most people do and I was
waiting for the bom
CL the Puerto Rican pom
pom that whiches
boy I love rude boy yeah that was soon
come back yeah my roommates in college
were Jamaican and that when they'd start
talking you wouldn't understand a
[__] oh that's so fun so classic what
the [__] dude it's so entertaining I
listen to a lot of their music now I've
been getting to like a lot of like that
afro music it's so sick very
entertaining I bet you do out in Costa
Rica just doing your
thing you guys doing it right Island bre
I'm my freshing yeah
yeah Bob Marley was talking about that
it was talking about how you know part
of a huge part of his childhood was
going to bed hungry like for real hungry
you know and uh and then you know just
got to a point where he had this real
talent and felt like his dad was white
his dad was British and his mother was
Jamaican and he kind of felt like this
composite man he felt like he had a
responsibility to kind of bring people
together the way he had been brought
together almost you know it really cool
did now did he did did he shot no he had
cancer he got a brain tumor um he had
yeah he had yeah he his he couldn't
figure out why he was tired all the time
and then he would play soccer to try to
get himself going and then then he just
one day he was like this is not working
and he went to the doctor and they were
like you got a GL blastoma right so
what's next for you boys what's coming
up as far as juu wise or one
Championship wise yeah so I I think um
one early I think January 14th there's
two dates in January um two cards I
think we're both going to be on I don't
know if we're both going to be on one
both going to be on one or the either
but definitely in January we're both
going to be on one events probably
Jiu-Jitsu for those and then following
hopefully my MMA
debut what weight do you uh you guys
split that's been the one thing for MMA
or Jiu-Jitsu Jiu-Jitsu Jiu-Jitsu 170 and
185 my brother just secured the 185 P
belt his last fight and then uh I just
been fting out one so you're a little
thicker yes
[Applause]
boy hold hold wait you're a little
stronger a little stronger guaranteed
guar probably a little bit start
fermenting a little more I don't know
about it's a different type of Str he
might be I don't know about punching now
he's not going and is is there opponent
for those yet have they have they talked
about opponents nothing yet um I think
uh nothing solidified yet I think
they're talking to some guys I think
we're really trying to see what happens
at this next noi worlds see what who
comes out on top ped marinho yeah he
just called me out on that last one yeah
he's all
psyched I'm coming for
you brother let's go damn it's always
somebody right there's always somebody
and then then your gold as you mentioned
before Gordon Ryan that would H how
would what would we have to do to make
that happen because it wouldn't be in
one Championship right cuz he's not a
one Championship guy he was signed the
one for was for a while yeah and then I
don't know what I think I never really
understood why he never fought for one
but then occurred to me that there was
drug testing for once
know then it occurred to me I don't
think you want I don't think anybody
wants piece of Ryan like Gordon when
he's Saucy and he's 235 he's also he's
also tall he's also he's big guy I mean
I mean you could that's that he people
don't really realize how strong that man
is how
physically Luke rockle told me that he
goes they're strong and then there's
Gordon Ryan he said so you want him
though right like you don't want a like
an older Gorden Ryan I
want wants he's going to be in his prime
for the next couple years you know I
feel like yeah strong he's still in his
20 28 yeah he's so great he posted the
thing when he shaved his beard he goes
I'm Gordon Ryan and I'm 28 years old
yeah I'm not he was looking old with
that beard he he dies at White you know
he looks for sure but uh well boys we
appreciate man you're a breath fresh
year man you guys are [__] superstars
pleasure the first thing said is he goes
these guys have the best
energy look at him he's great that's
yeah he does look a lot so young it's
unreal that's classic he is jacked yeah
he is he looked like us before he gained
like 60
lbs look
on look like us love he posted that
though that was after him being super
yeah that's that [__] whatever's going
on there that's that's Tren or something
that's some of that bodybuilding steroid
that's like everything and anything yeah
boy jacked all right we appreciate you
guys man so much can't thank you
enough
you for us on the I'm a
fan